I told you new hugs away from me
are you going to order him to kill
I'm the only one you have left our
children are gone her father is gone
it's just me and you now
this woman yet to come I don't know
hey everybody is Charlie Nikolaj
coster-waldau has been doing more
interviews about the final season jaime
and cersei 'he's character arts talking
about their unborn child so wanted to do
a video explaining why that baby is
doomed now everybody has their own
theories about why that is but there
have been many scenes in previous
seasons of the show as well as the books
that give you an idea for where the show
is headed so no spoilers for season 8 no
worries there this is all just based on
stuff that we've already seen so if
you're brand new to the channel there's
a new round of that 4k blu-ray giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video right after that final moment with
jaime and cersei during the finale a lot
of people were wondering if Circe was
lying about her pregnancy because we
found out about it a couple episodes
before this even Jamie thought it was a
crazy idea like what this is ridiculous
but you can kind of see how they're
slowly setting up Cersei as madness arc
from the comics from book 4 really like
she slowly starts to go bad feels like
she starts hearing things but you lose a
lot of that because we don't get Cersei
POV chapters on the TV show so the way
they pay that off is with scenes like
Jaime and Cersei have here where she
seemingly makes the worst possible
decision ever like sees all this
evidence about the night king Jaime's
ready to go help them out and Cersei
just takes a complete left turn like you
know what we're just gonna sit here we
have our unborn child that's all that
matters just the three of us our family
and the fighting in the north is over
someone went you understand that don't
you
if the dead win they must SAP and kill
us all if the living win and we've
betrayed them they march it is probably
the craziest decision she could have
made so that's them slowly paying off
her madness arc so the baby itself is
not fake she's not lying about that so
when people ask Nikolaj coster-waldau to
clarify what he meant when he says I
don't believe you in this moment he says
that in his mind Jaime is saying that I
don't love you anymore and I don't want
any part of this like just pointing at
everything that's happening in King's
Landing I don't want any part in any
more of your and that includes her
pregnancy too so he does believe the
baby exists but he doesn't believe in
the family anymore so he's rejecting the
idea that they have a future together as
a family
so his Ridge
section of that notion is one piece of
evidence so just another brick in the
wall of evidence that this baby will not
come to pass like it will not come to
term
Yury watch the Maggy the Frog scene that
also gives you all the evidence that you
need to know what's going to happen to
search these baby because everything
that maggie has said both in the books
and the TV show version has come true so
far so I'll read the book version
because it's a little more complete but
Cersei says when will I Wed the Prince
Maggie says never you will Wed the king
I will be queen though I Queen you shall
be until there comes another younger and
more beautiful to cast you down and take
all that you hold dear so that's the
first part she was actually as a young
girl asking if she would Wed Rhaegar
Targaryen and Maggie was saying no
you're Wed the king talking about Robert
Baratheon which she did so she did
become queen until the younger more
beautiful Marjorie came along and took
all that she held dear which was Tommen
through Cersei and Marjorie's actions
Tommen had turned against Cersei so he
had been taken quote-unquote from her
then it goes on
Cersei says will the King and I have
children and Maggie says oh I six and
ten for him and three for you Gold shall
be their crowns and gold their shrouds
the funny part about that is the Cersei
totally didn't get what she was talking
about in the moment like that doesn't
make sense but when she said six and ten
for him she was talking about all of
Roberts bastards like Gendry three
includes the three children that she had
with Jaime gold shall be their crowns
meaning that they would all have golden
hair gold will be their shrouds
prophesying that they would eventually
die which they all eventually did Maggie
is even more accurate to because then
Circe's friend who's standing with her
their melara Heather spoon says will I
marry Jaime because she wanted to know
if she'd eventually marry Circe's
brother Maggie says not Jaime nor any
other man worms will have your
Maidenhead your death is here tonight
little one can you smell her breath she
is very close this is the really awesome
book payoff that the show never gave us
because what she's talking about is is
that Melora was actually dead having
been pushed down a well meaning that she
never had sex with anyone so that's what
the whole worms will have your
and headline was all about your death
here tonight means that Cersei probably
pushed her down the well because Cersei
wanted Jaime for herself she was that
selfish even at that young age so you
have to imagine how cold and calculated
Cersei is even at this young they walk
away from Maggy the Frog Cersei
confident that she'll become Queen
someday not totally understanding some
of Maggie's more cryptic statements but
then suddenly realizing is they were
passing by a well that her friend was
going to eventually try and take Jaime
away from her
so she pushed her down that well that's
why Maggie said your death is here
tonight can you smell her breath meaning
can you smell Circe's breath because
she's standing right next to you your
death is literally in this room with you
right here so in the mind of george RR
martin that is how accurate Maggy the
Frog is supposed to be so if Maggie says
you're only going to have three children
that means this Cersei is probably only
gonna have three children meaning number
four the bun in the oven will not come
to term like either it'll be stillborn
or she will die in the process of giving
birth to it if you want to believe the
twisted version of the valonqar that
would actually be a pretty badass payoff
to the valonqar prophecy but if you're
holding out hope for something like that
I still feel like Jaime's death in
Circe's death will be linked there are a
couple moments in the books where both
of the characters talk about how they're
so closely linked in how their deaths
will eventually be linked during Storm
of Swords jamie has a POV chapter where
he says I cannot die while Cersei lives
he told himself we will die together as
we were born together then later during
feast for crows Cersei says during her
POV chapter we will leave this world
together as we once came into it that
finally in the book six epilogue Cersei
is talking to herself thinking about
Jaime and she says if he were dead I
would know it we came into this world
together uncle he would not go without
me you have to remember that this moment
during the finale where Jaime tell
Cersei to screw off happened much
earlier in the books so during this book
six epilogue she's just thinking about
what he might be doing out there she
just hears rumors about where Jaime's at
so all those scenes from the books and
the TV show just for shado that this
baby will not come to pass not that it's
fake only that it won't survive the
pregnancy one of the reasons why I think
the TV show Cho
to do that for Circe's storyline because
I don't think that it's going to be
happening in the books the same way is
because they wanted the Jaime Cersei
break at this moment here where he
leaves her to feel much more significant
like there's the potential for a family
because she has a baby like oh we could
actually be a family if we really tried
but by this point Cersei is turning into
the mad Queen and circumstances are what
they are we all knew that eventually
Jaime would leave they just wanted this
moment to be that much more impactful so
if you're wondering what the reason for
that baby is that's probably why so let
me know in the comments do you think
that the baby's death will be linked to
Circe's death and I'll say
congratulations to the giveaway winner
from my last big video Chris Roberts
please email me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details click here to learn all about
vissarion in the night king they just
clarified a whole bunch of details and
click here to learn all about the
prequel long night TV series thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight